and finally new rules since this is our
last show before the holidays let's
remember to never lose sight of the true
meaning of the season it's not about
presents and fruitcake and putting up
extra lights to show that you love Jesus
more than your neighbor it's about a
teenage virgin getting knocked up by God
as depicted here in Botticelli's
masterpiece Mary age 12 gets a visit
from judge Roy Moore and since this will
be president Trump's first Christmas in
the White House I thought it would be
appropriate to take a page out of
Christmas favorites like a Christmas
carol and it's a Wonderful Life where a
character has shown an alternative
reality to their life like when an angel
named Clarence shows George Bailey what
the world would be like if he'd never
been born huh
what if Donald trum had never been born
was that as good for you as it was for
me now in A Christmas Carol
Eponine Scrooge is visited by the ghost
of Christmas past and since Donald Trump
is truly the Ebenezer Scrooge of our
time
angry rich and hard to look at maybe
tonight I could play the part of the
ghost and show Trump an alternative
reality of what his life could have been
if he weren't such a [ __ ]
[Music]
so Donald's let me take you back back
all the way back all right not that far
but far enough back to remind you that
even though you're a big man now flying
in the big plane and let me get the big
house and eating the Big Mac are you
truly happy what happened to that little
boy from Queens here you are as a
toddler the last time you had a good
hair day your father was a strict
authoritarian is that where it all
started to go wrong because you know you
weren't always the wrestling villain you
are today you used to say things like
I'm not looking to make tremendous
amounts of money I'm looking to enjoy my
life Donald Trump saying there's more to
life than money what happened to this
Donald Trump did you hide him with your
Russia connections did you divorce him
when he hit menopause you even used to
show humility no matter how bright a
person may be there is always that
element of love did you hear that dog
not the greatest of the smartest only I
could fix it I want that trump back he
spoke softly and wasn't a big dick
even had vulnerability you weren't
afraid to show affection to Don jr. and
to to Eric and to Ivanka especially to
Ivanka you even dressed in a more
vulnerable fashion like the world's
whitest pimp
and when Rona Barrett asked you what was
more important work or love you said I
would probably choose love choose love
not [ __ ] grabbing careful Don it's a
slippery slope to compassion because the
old Trump even used to worry about the
poor New York City has been becoming a
city of the very rich actually and the
poor unfortunately and the middle class
are having a hard time here that you
acknowledge the existence of poor people
I know it's so strange hearing those
words now come out of your mouth it's
like when the little girl in the
Exorcist says your mother sucks [ __ ] in
hell
last year when David Duke endorsed you
you claimed you didn't know him but you
sure knew who he was two decades ago
well you've got David Duke just joined a
bigot a racist a problem I mean this is
not exactly the people you want in your
party but now it's exactly the people
you want in your party
do you see Don do you see what spending
the last 20 years watching Fox News has
done to your brain is it too late to
bring back the old Trump how the [ __ ]
should I know I'm a ghost not
Nostradamus but I do know you better be
good Donald Trump because there's a
jolly man who lives up north who hangs
out with reindeer and watches everything
and his name is Vladimir Putin